Allen even Stein author of Friedrich
Hayek why do you think people want to
know about this man I think that
Friedrich Hayek is possibly the most
important political philosopher of the
20th century and in the same way that
Karl Marx during the 19th century put
forward ideas that were implemented
during the 20th century I think that
Hayek's ideas in the 21st century may be
of great importance where did you first
learn about him I first learned about
Hayek as a student at the London School
of Economics where Hayek had taught I
was a student there during the mid-1980s
and read his book the Road to Serfdom
when did he live Hayek was born in 1899
and he died in 1992 he was from Austria
and grew up still in pre-world War 1
austria-hungary the austro-hungarian
Empire and he then moved to London
during the 1930s and 40s and
subsequently went to Chicago and then
back to Europe for his later decades so
he was a man whose life spans almost the
entire 20th century and who lived
throughout the European and American
world when did he first come to
America's attention Hayek actually was a
student in America in 1923 24 and that I
think was vital in his intellectual
development so as a young student he he
he came to America and studied at New
York University he studied economics
after being in the United States for a
year he returned to Vienna subsequently
he went to the London School of
Economics he was in America from 1950 to
1962 at the University of Chicago Milton
Friedman was at the University of
Chicago at that time and others his most
well-known book the road to serfdom was
published in 1944 so he really became
known in the United States several years
before he came here to teach what did he
say in the road to serfdom that got
everybody's attention I think the
crucial idea of the road to serfdom
is that without economic freedom there
cannot be political freedom Hayek tried
to tie political freedom and economic
freedom together and this was a very
different idea than existed during the
1930s and 40s when there was the idea of
democratic socialism that there could be
a socialism government control of a
nation's economy and yet still have
democracy Hayek said that that would not
be possible that instead without a
free-market system there could be no
democracy how old was he when this
picture was taken this picture was taken
when he was at the London School of
Economics so he was probably in his 30s
at that time and while the numbers on
the cover I think that that's to
indicate that he was an economist he was
both an economist and a political
philosopher and for the first several
decades of his career he was primarily
an economist and then he moved into the
area of political theory he received the
Nobel Prize in Economics in 1974 so I
think the idea of the numbers is to tie
in the economic aspect of Hayek's
thought another Nobel Peace Prize winner
James Buchanan is out here George Mason
around the DC area the university is
quoted in your book as saying I never
called him Fritz why would he say that
Hayek was a formal man he was not
particularly outgoing or warm he was
more an aloof intellectual and we should
say as well that James McCann and
received the Nobel Prize in Economics
not about the Peace Prize as Hayek did
and Hayek and Buchanan were close
through an organization called the Mont
Pelerin Society and that's an
International Society of classical
liberals and libertarians free market
oriented economists and Hayek was
reserved he was a man who was it was an
excellent teacher many of his teachers
many of his students speak to his his
knowledge and his his great intellectual
ability and at the same time they speak
of him being a reserved man not someone
who would
talk readily about his family life or
his personal life but rather someone who
was most interested in ideas and their
consequences
I made the mistake of saying Nobel Peace
Prize which leads me to when I ask you
what's the difference between getting
the Peace Prize and an economics prize
Nobel originally there were five no
bells when the Nobel Prize was
established in 1900 and actually I think
the first award was given in 1901 the
Nobel Prize in Economic Sciences was
first given in 1969 and Hayek received
the Nobel Prize in Economics in 1974 and
he was the first free-market economist
to receive the Nobel Prize prior to that
time it had primarily been Keynesian x'
who had received the Nobel Prize
so when Hayek received a Nobel Prize in
1974 in economics it was a real event
because the free-market view a pro
capitalist view was being acknowledged
as a respectable way of looking at the
world this is something that was very
different from the way Hayek had been
treated earlier in his career when he
had written the road to serfdom and some
of his other works and he had been
considered virtually a reactionary crank
for the views that he put forward so it
was something that the Nobel Prize had a
great influence on Hayek in terms of
bringing him to national and
international attention again how many
copies of the road to serfdom so to the
United States there have a since it was
originally published in 1944 it was a
best-seller at the time Hayek came to
the United States from England at that
time and participated in a world wind
tour and was on the Brian lambs show of
the time in terms of the the c-span
booknotes of course this was before TV
but he had a world wind tour of the
United States and so it sold a lot at
that time it since sold hundreds of
thousands of copies so all told there's
probably 300,000 to 400,000 or so copies
of the Road to Serfdom that have sold
it's been translated into over 20
languages sometimes unauthorized foreign
language translations too
countries in the former the former
Eastern communist Eastern Europe and the
Soviet Union before the Berlin Wall fell
Hayek's works would be circulated in
typewritten translated copies so he's
someone who has had a great influence
not just in the Western world but in the
formerly communist world he's considered
to be one of the greatest intellectuals
who put forward the idea that it's not
possible to have an effective command
economy it's not that it would be
ethically or morally undesirable to have
a socialist system where the government
owns all the land runs all the
businesses it's simply that a system
like that doesn't work when he put
forward these ideas in the 1930s this
was considered to be just not even a
position almost worth considering
however it's since become the
conventional wisdom almost and it's
something that since that time since
we've seen the collapse of the Soviet
Union and of the economies in Eastern
Europe Hayek has largely been vindicated
by events and his his predictions of the
way the world works
what did Reader's Digest have to do with
the success of this years ago wrote the
road to serfdom was originally put into
a Digest forum by The Reader's Digest
and as a result of that and this is
before the TV age the The Reader's
Digest at that time had a circulation of
something like 12 million people so it
was a much more significant part of the
American intellectual scene than it has
subsequently become right as Hayek was
coming to the United States he had this
Reader's Digest version that was
published so all of a sudden he was not
just well-known within academic and
literary circles but the general public
and so his lecture tour in the United
States was changed from a rather
scholarly sedate tour to a more popular
tour and he tells a story of going to
his first lecture in New York that was
unanticipated in terms of what sort of
address it would be and he gets on the
stage and he says now what am I supposed
to talk about
they say well you're gonna have to speak
on international law and he says I've
never talked on that before and they
said well it has to be exactly 45
minutes and by the way you're on the
radio so he'd never done this sort of
lecturing before but he proved to be
very adept at it and as a result of The
Reader's Digest lead article his work
became well-known to a wide public at
that time where do you live and what do
you do for a living I'm I live in Santa
Barbara California and I am an
independent scholar and also the
director of research for the Arthur and
Ruth foundation what is the foundation
what's the name the the Arthur and Roop
foundation is a foundation that is
interested in philanthropic activities
with an idea towards social change what
we're interested in doing is working
toward changing public policy and
promoting education in a free-market
line so Hayek is someone who were very
interested in and his sorts of ideas and
what was the name again roots the Arthur
and Roop and who is he
our our troop is the founder he formerly
was the owner and director of specialty
records and he had people on his label
like Sonny Bono and Little Richard and
other leading stars during the 1950s and
1960s and he since created a foundation
is he still alive yes he is and how did
you get into that well art and I met
through political activities I was a
candidate for the local California State
Assembly and he and I met in an event
and stuck a struck up a friendship and
have been in contact since then where
did you go to school I attended the UCSB
the University of California at Santa
Barbara for my undergraduate work and
then I did my PhD at the London School
of Economics who is William even Steiner
you refer to in the book sure William
even Stein is my father and or was my
father he was a student himself at the
London School of Economics during the
1930s when Hayek was a professor there
my father liked Hayek was from Vienna
and he was born 11 years after Hayek and
after graduating from the University as
Hayek did he went to the University
via my kayak my father went to the
University in Vienna and then after
being at the University of Vienna like
Hayek my father went to the London
School of Economics and then after being
at the London School of Economics my
father taught briefly at the University
of Chicago which is where Hayek came
when he came to the United States so
actually from a familial perspective
this was a an interesting and fun
project because it was almost tracing my
father's background my father however
was a student of some of Hayek's leading
bettan wores at both the University of
Vienna and the London School of
Economics at the University of Vienna
hands Kelson was a leading progressive
philosopher who my father was a student
of and then at the London School of
Economics my father was a student of
Harold Laski who was the leading
Democratic socialists of the day and
perhaps Hayek's archrival at the London
School of Economics so it was it was an
interesting project from the perspective
of getting to know some of the people
who are in my own background as well
better
what were your father's politics my
father started out as a Democratic
Socialist and in fact in the boat book
he then became a professor at Princeton
University and at the University of
California at Santa Barbara and he was
one of those who criticized Hayek after
Hayek originally published the road to
serfdom for suggesting that planning
would not be possible however my
father's views emerge of evolved and as
time went on he took a more Hayekian
view I remember him mentioning to me
after Hayek received the Nobel Prize in
1974 he said that well it's about time
that they they gave him the award it was
long overdue and that it's a shame that
he had to split it when Hayek received
the Nobel Prize in 1974 he received it
with the Swedish socialist Gunnar Meyer
Dahl and my dad said to said to me I
remember him mentioning that it was a it
was it was about time that Hayek had
received it and that was a shame he had
to split it I Ron
when I read in Hayek's correspondence I
read the correspondence to him written
by Milton Friedman after after he
received the after Hayek received a
Nobel Prize but Friedman's comment to
Hayek was exactly the same Oh something
dear fritz it's taken far too long for
you to receive the award and even then
the Swedes only went half the way but
that's more than I expected them to do
so now one of the reasons that we wanted
to ask you here to do this is because
over the years booknotes is over 12
years old the name Hayek I never heard
the name before I started this show it
pops up all the time so in order for us
to kind of get on the same wavelength as
our audience has been over the years and
a lot in the audience don't hear the
name as it's talked about we're gonna go
back and run a number of clips of people
who you will recognize talking about
this the first one is from an interview
just a couple of weeks ago with the
Chief Justice the United States and
we'll roll this and get your response to
this the first really controversial or
advocacy book I ever read was when I was
in this in the Air Force and it was
Friedrich Hayek Friedrich Hayek's the
Road to Serfdom and I was used to just
you know textbooks that would set forth
a bunch of facts and you're supposed to
memorize the facts and recite them back
on the 10th on the test but this book
was an advocacy book trying to show that
state planning and socialism and that
that sort of a thing didn't work
economically and was dangerous
politically and it made quite a quite an
impression on me there were just by luck
at Oxford at that time a number of
Americans who were interested in
Friedrich von Hayek that's what the Cato
Institute does we take the ideas of
people like John Locke and Adam Smith
and Friedrich Hayek and apply them to
issues of the day well because he's a
very profound man mind and very clear
and I think conservative and it
convinces you the conservatism is the
correct approach he's a
he's written a great deal or very
valuable friedrich hayek
who's one of the gods of the the Reagan
a Friedman ideology Friedrich I would
knock your head off if you call them a
conservative he would he was in Austria
and he's conservatives of people who
believe in in in the emperor believe in
the state Church believe in a strong
state he was a liberal there you have it
there's it all over the lot I think that
what these clips indicate is that Hayek
is a thinker who appeals to individuals
of all political perspectives and I
think that goes to the idea that when
Marx wrote during the 19th century he
was not well recognized during his time
in the reviews of Marx before the
Russian Revolution in 1917 he's referred
to as a socialistic commentator and
agitator and that might be the view of
Hayek today in terms of he's known in a
broader circle but he's not famous in
the sense of in a sense that some others
are famous Keynes for example might be a
better example of the economists or
Friedman to an extent who's the most
well-known today
Hayek's renown is not as great as either
Keynes or freedmen but I think that
Hayek is someone who enunciated a vision
a way of looking at the world a a world
that could be different than the way
that it is I think that's why some
people refer to him as a liberal some
people refer to him as a conservative
Hayek himself would have referred to
himself as a nineteenth-century liberal
he didn't particularly like the word
libertarian but that was the the view
that was closest to his own he did not
like conservatism his postscript to his
1960 work the constitution of Liberty is
explicitly titled why I am NOT a
conservative and he criticizes
conservatism for its power adoring
characteristics for the idea of a very
establishment social order for the idea
of power and Society he didn't like
those ideas
non-governmental sources of power to
society go back to what Chief Justice
Rehnquist's said about you know the
first book that he ever read that was
something he picked on his own and had
made quite an impression on him does
that surprise you in any way I mean what
you know about it not at all it's it's
something that that's a reaction that
many have when they first read Hayek's
works that it's a new way of looking at
the world there are many individuals who
say that reading the Road to Serfdom or
some of Hayek's other works have had a
significant influence on them and I
think what's so important about Hayek's
work is that he's really challenging the
way people look at the world and I think
that particularly in regard to socialism
the argument wasn't that socialism would
be undesirable or that people weren't
altruistic enough to be social for
socialism to work but rather that
factually socialism couldn't deliver the
goods because in order to have an
effective economy you have to have
prices you have to have profits you have
to have the ability for people to
exchange services goods and services
this is a different idea than much of
the mindset and ideology the way of
looking at the world so it's something
that when people read it it often
changes their way of looking at the
world George will refer it very quickly
there just a little comment about Oxford
Wood Hayek have been studied at Oxford
and what were the politics of the Oxford
Dawn's at this point in time Hayek is
probably the most well known in England
of any country in the world particularly
as a result of having lived there for
almost 20 years his his family lives in
in his children still live in England oh
yes now I was able to spend several
weekends with Larry Hayek and Eska Hayek
and visit their home and I had the
opportunity to research their personal
files and letters and clippings and
articles and those sorts of things how
old are they now at this point in time
Larry was born I think in 1933 so he'd
be 67 68 years old something along those
and what's he do he's he's a medical
doctor and he's tried to continue his
father's work from the perspective of
making sure that
the procedural and administrative
aspects are taken care what about the
daughter his daughter several years
older she was a bacteriologist for the
British Museum so she's someone who also
has a scientific background and as you
know you wrote about there was quite
controversy over his first and second
marriage and they are from his first
marriage they're both from his first
marriage Hayek had a divorce from his
first wife she his first wife would not
give him a divorce so ultimately he came
to the United States in considerable
part to be able to establish residency
in 1950 in Arkansas which at that time
was about the only place that had
permissive no-fault divorce laws he then
was able to obtain a divorce and then
subsequently married his second cousin
while he married a cousin of his who had
been a childhood sweetheart so it was
something that was not in an entirely
happy chapter in his life as Larry
refers to it but what do they think of
it
well I think that it was very hard on
them at the time at the same time Hayek
was someone who was dedicated to his
work and in talking both too
particularly to his daughter she made a
comment along the lines that I hardly
knew my father because he spent so much
time researching and writing this was
his primary activity it's also been
suggested to me that in part as a result
of his unhappy family circumstances this
was part of the reason why he wrote as
much as he did but I think the truth is
that Hayek was someone who was
absolutely committed to the life of the
mind and regardless of his family
circumstances he would have been a pure
scholar why what was the reason for the
divorce and was it abrupt it was it was
strictly a matter that he wanted to read
he wanted to marry his cousin they had
been as young people they had been in a
relationship he then left for the United
States when he came back as a result of
miscommunication she was then in another
relationship and they didn't marry at
that time they considered trying to
marry before World War two but decided
not to and then as a result of World War
two his second wife was in Austria
during World War two so they had no
contact for almost six or seven years
after the war they decided Hayek says in
his autobiographical notes that whatever
the costs he'd have to seek a divorce
and that's what he did what year did he
divorced he divorced in 1950 and he
lived - what year again 1992 he was old
he was all two months short of his 93rd
birthday and Road to Serfdom came out
again what year 1944 let's look at some
more videotape and look at what others
have said about him on this show in the
last 12 years philosophical work I think
I would pick - if I could
one is Hayek's constitution of Liberty
and the others the book I just referred
to by James James Stephan called liberty
equality fraternity a year and a half
before I tried to write the book that's
who I was reading I said well who who
can comment on these things and I just
reading all our read Hayek I read
Woodrow Wilson Cardozo Holmes in the
early days of the conservative movement
when hurt when Friedrich Hayek's book
the Road to Serfdom came out there
weren't a lot of publishing houses eager
to publish it in this country
it wasn't conventional
Hayek had a profound impact on me am i
thinking I read the road to serfdom very
early in the mid-50s why is it so
important because it is such a
succinctly and powerful statement of
what is wrong with collectivism
with socialism with any form of
authoritarian government why such
governments are don't work economically
and also destructive of personal liberty
I'm kind of a populist I believe that
that the common people out there in the
country are really pretty smart
they may not be able to tell you about
Keynes and Hayek and all that but they
they have a kind of a street sense of
what's working and what isn't out it out
in the street these men all have touched
on what you've written about at
different times in the book let me start
with Bob material saying that he had a
hard time getting published in this
country is that true I think so
when Hayek first attempted to publish
the road to serfdom it was taken to
three different publishers none of whom
accepted it and one of the reviewers
wrote back that although the book might
do well it had an ideological viewpoint
that wouldn't be appropriate to be
published by a leading publishing house
so it was the case that at that point in
time the views that Hayek was putting
forward were not popular views about
Bartley's the editor of The Wall Street
Journal and he calls himself a populist
and thinks that the people are pretty
smart out there but they might not know
who either Keynes or high or is that do
you agree with that I think that it's
the case that the as Keynes said the
ideas of political philosophers econo
and economists both for good nil are
more powerful than it's commonly
understood it's not necessarily the case
that the individuals who enunciate ideas
are known to the general public
but their ideas percolate through the
areas of journalism academia and media
of other sorts and then generally become
common views so I think that it is often
the case that the people who put forward
ideas are not well-known what is the
primary difference between John Maynard
Keynes and Friedrich Hayek I think the
primary and Hayek and Keynes knew each
other well during the 1930s as Hayek
came to the London School of Economics
he immediately started out with just a
blistering confrontation with Keynes on
some of the economic issues of the day
and Hayek wrote a blistering review of
one of Keynes's books and then Keynes
did a response to Hayek's review where
he says that professor Hayek's review is
an outstanding example of how a logician
starting from a wrong premise can end up
in bedlam not withstand
that rather inauspicious start they
became good friends and during World War
two in fact the London School of
Economics was relocated to Cambridge
where Keynes was and Keynes and Hayek
would take turns at night watching for
fires as Britain was being bombed from
the top of King's College in Cambridge
so they knew each other well I think the
primary difference between Keynes and
Hayek is that Keynes was a welfare state
interventionist he was not a socialist
he did not believe in government
management and operation of a nation's
economy but he believed in a large role
for government in a nation's economy
through demand management through active
support for unions for a strong welfare
state whereas Hayek is more a pure free
market economist more of a libertarian
Hayek's view is that the smaller the
state the less government the better so
they differed in their views in that
regard
David Frum when we saw the first on that
clip is now writing speeches for george
w bush does that track i think so i
think that i think that the within the
united states there are aspects of
Hayek's message that appeals both two
Democrats and two Republicans I think
that from an economic perspective
Republicans are probably closer to
Hayek's message but I think that from a
civil liberties perspective that
Democrats are probably closer to Hayek's
message so it's it's a message that can
find support the the idea of less
government is is an idea that in
different ways appeals to both sides of
the political spectrum David Fromm
mentioned constitution of Liberty and
liberty equality and fraternity you star
those in your book as two of his most
important works you say there are four
really important works how many did he
write altogether hiya Croatoan for
twenty books and they range from
technical economics to the history of
ideas to psychology and then later in
his career primarily in the area of
political philosophy political theory
history and the history of
ideas all wonderful books in terms of I
think that the Road to Serfdom is
probably the the easiest book for a
general reader to get into and and
something that as many of the people let
me just ask you about the general reader
to take the first note that it doesn't
consider themselves being intellectual
they don't know economics any more than
they're just you know reading it every
day in the newspaper why would they want
to buy and read Road to just the Road to
Serfdom I think that the Road to Serfdom
remains a valuable book for
understanding the essence of a
free-market economy why it is that a
free-market economy is economically
productive but more than that why a
free-market economy is the only free
society that's possible that if people
don't have freedom and their economic
lives to buy and sell as they wish to
exchange on the terms that they see fit
that really there's not much political
freedom either so as an introduction to
the idea of the tie between economic
freedom and political freedom I think
it's an outstanding work for that I
mentioned that we've heard about Hayek
on this show over 620 books over the
last 12 years the other person we hear
about a lot never about three or four of
them is Alexis de Tocqueville Road to
Serfdom came you say from Tocqueville
absolutely
originally the title of the road to
serfdom was going to be the road to
servitude which is a line from
Tocqueville and Hayek decided to change
that to the road to serfdom because he
thought that it sounded better
but Hayek was definitely in that school
of 19th century political writers who
believed
also as Thoreau put it that government
is best which governs least so it it is
a different idea than government as it's
emerged and I think that Hayek's
analysis is a sophisticated analysis of
how those ideas are applicable to the
21st century as well as the 19th
Friedrich Andrew von Hayek I believe is
this Friedrich August von so thank you
I'm sorry
von what's it mean von was a title of
nobility in the austro-hungarian Empire
there were four levels of nobility von
was
the lowest of those four levels it's
English approximation would be sir you
also have a ludwig von mises in your
book lubbers he Ludwig von Mises was
Hayek's teacher he was not at the
University of Vienna as a result of
anti-semitism Mises was Jewish he was
not able to teach at the University of
Vienna but he ran an agency called the
Chamber of Commerce which was not like
our Chamber of Commerce which is a
non-profit but was an agency of the
government and Hayek worked for Mises
front for 10 years from 1921 to 1931
Mises was a great free-market economist
who participated in something called the
socialist calculation debate during the
1920s when the idea was really being
considered in Austria to nationalize the
economy he argued strongly against
nationalization and Hayek then applied
some of these ideas later in his career
you say that Hayek was Catholic did he
practice no he was not a practicing
Catholic he was he was born a Roman
Catholic however his father was a
botanist as his grandfather was a
biologist he had a strictly Darwinian
view of the world he considered himself
to be an agnostic let's look at some
more videotape and get some more ideas
from what people have said on this
program and then the economists after
World War two came to the United States
either Mikolas in the case of Hayek and
some others by way of England and and
rejection of the socialist tendencies of
the time in Austria which they didn't
like and then later in escape from
Hitler and so American public life was
enormous Lee refreshed my can academic
life was enormous Lee refreshed by this
Austrian migration even though it was by
my standards most of it much more
conservative than I would be disposed to
be
and Prague free Prague and free Warsaw
and free Budapest young men and women
and old men and women who heretofore had
been having their fingers broken by
communists run shion's for expressing
their belief and freedom those people
are now in power all over Eastern Europe
and they are they treat Hayek as a kind
of founding father and they talked to
people like me from the United States
when we visit Prague and Budapest as
though we read Hayek every morning I
mean they think he's a formidable force
and their course their appraisals
correct now Bob taro was here almost ten
years ago when he said that that was not
too far from when the wall fell and all
that
do they still think he's that important
over in Eastern Europe absolutely no I
I'd say that among the free market
forces in the former communist world
that Hayek probably stands taller than
any other thinker so once again that's
within a more intellectual circle but
it's something that perhaps even more so
than in the West
his ideas really were directed more
against classical socialism the idea of
government management and ownership and
control of all of a nation's economy
which is really more applicable to the
communist and Eastern European model in
England it also has quite a bit of
influence because they had many
industries that were nationalized I
think the arguments against the welfare
state are more difficult and Hayek had
himself difficulty with where do you
draw the line of government John Kenneth
Galbraith seemed to be friendly toward
him he he was hi Hayek actually was as a
professor at the London School of
Economics Galbraith was a visiting
junior scholar for one year and sat in
on Hayek seminar which he recalls fondly
and I think that where Galbraith
particularly although he disagrees
strongly with Hayek's work he believes
that he's an honest writer and that he
sets forth his views clearly and
accurately
he's just long but he's
motivated by any sort of desire to do
anything other than what he thinks
really is the best showed this picture
of Ronald Reagan earlier what year was
this this was I believe in 1983 in a
Olaf in the Oval Office Reagan once met
Hayek and mentioned to him that he'd
read one of his books and learned a
great deal from it the same goes for
Barry Goldwater was a great admirer of
Hayek Margaret Thatcher in England and
Winston Churchill as well read the Road
to Serfdom in England so it's something
that Hayek as someone who's had great
influence particularly on the leading
conservative economic political leaders
in the United States in England during
the last half century you discussed the
relationship between Margaret Thatcher
and mr. Hayek in your book was it
friendly was it mean there was a point
where people thought he was a part of
her administration Thatcher was very
friendly toward Hayek and looked at him
as her leading philosophical inspirer at
the same time it shouldn't be thought as
as the one comment was about that people
read Hayek every morning that they were
on the phone constantly she saw him
perhaps only several times a year often
in an in a semi social manner so it was
something that he was more an inspirer
of thought and someone who put forward
philosophical ideas rather than someone
who was an active government adviser on
the issues of the day he really didn't
offer too much advice on the issues of
the day occasionally he'd get involved
on an individual basis but it wasn't
from the perspective of his of his
thought did you ever meet him
I never met him no have you ever seen
him on film or on tape oh yes many a
number of times what would you see well
Hayek was someone who he had a
relatively strong accent but he also
spoke in a somewhat soft voice he was a
tall man somewhat thin he had a
moustache very urbane and his style he
had a good sense of humor he was
self-deprecating
and at the same time very profound
someone who you really learned you're
one really learns from listening to him
that he genuinely is someone who has a
different view of the world in terms of
our society can be different than the
way it is now and I think that's
something that is too often forgotten
there's a feeling that whatever exists
now is the way things always are going
to be and the way they've always been
whereas if there's one thing we learn
from history it's that the future will
be completely unlike the present we
don't know how it's going to be but we
should know that it's going to be
completely different Hayek is someone
who really had a completely different
view of the world and he tried to
enunciate it and obviously it's it's a
view that has inspired many people you
paint a picture in the book of David
boas boses boss Edie Crane at the Cato
Institute where they have an auditorium
you say named after Friedrich guy
presenting a bust of Hayek - you have
guinea przemek off in this Russia back
in the early 1990s what why would he do
that and and what was the impact it was
a great moment it was actually in Moscow
that that IDI crane was presenting the
bust I should mention that I just was
able to give a presentation at the Cato
Institute and I have a another one on
the book that's gonna be at the
independent Institute were you in the
Hayek audit I was in the Hayek
auditorium and it's something that II D
crank presented this bust in Moscow as a
symbol of the ideas that underlie
political systems and that it's the
ideas of people like Hayek that have had
such an influence on the world in
leading to a different sort of social
system in the Soviets former Soviet
Union and elsewhere and Hayek although
very old at this point in time and ill
wrote wrote Crain back a letter saying
how pleased he was that the the bust had
been presented and he also said that he
had hardly live he hardly had expected
to be able to live to experience this
but since he lived until 1992 he was
actually able to go from the perspective
of someone who was completely ridiculed
for his idea that the Soviet type of
economy was a less effective economy to
someone whose ideas were vindicated
through the collapse of communism in the
so
in the fall of the Berlin Wall it should
be remembered that during the 1940s 50s
60s 70s even the 1980s in 1989 Paul
Samuelson wrote that the Soviet economy
is proof of the power of a collectivist
economy that was in his leading
economics textbook as recently as that
individuals thought that the Soviet
model of state direction was more
economically effective than a free
market based on profits prices private
property contract and so Hayek was able
to to live to see the triumph of his
ideas the first time we really talked at
length about a hike on this program was
this book which is the 50th anniversary
edition of the road to serfdom end they
the was written by Milton Friedman not
the book but the introduction and here's
a little bit about what he said then and
some more videotape from earlier book
most programs to kind of bring this all
around to the beginning Hayek and I had
been associated for a very long time in
particular in an organization called the
Mont Pelerin Society that he founded the
Charter meeting was in 1947 in
Switzerland and it was an attempt as a
Hans Morgenthau who was a professor at
the University of Chicago and I was
their political scientist when I came
back from the meeting he asked me where
I had been and I told him that I had
been to a meeting that had been called
by Hayek to try to bring together the
believers in the free open society and
enable them to have some interchange one
with another and he said Oh a meeting of
the veterans of the wars in the
nineteenth century and I thought that
was a wonderful description of the
MobileIron society well personally of
course when I met him he was a very old
man and so I remember a very old man of
old fashioned European demeanor a
gracious gentleman scholar who was
always so careful and precise to state
his objections to other people's ideas
without ever criticizing other people
personally he dedicated his book the
Road to Serfdom to the Socialists of all
parties and I think he was very sincere
and wanting to say I share your
aspirations I understand your dreams but
please read this warning of what will
happen if you let government have too
much power and he kept that respect for
every for all of his adversaries to the
end of his life now Milton Friedman
mentioned the Mont Pelerin Society and
there's a picture in your book of the
first meeting in 1947 you can see very
well but on the left is Milton Friedman
on the right is von Mises what is this
society does it still exist what did it
do well one of the real the outstanding
aspects of writing this book for me was
the opportunity to in the interview
Milton Friedman on two different
occasions and both Hayek and Friedman
were members of the Mont Pelerin Society
charter members the Mont Pelerin Society
is still in existence they meet every
year or two to discuss issues of the
free market and the free open society as
Friedman said and a number of members of
the Mont Pelerin Society particularly in
Europe have been leading government
statesmen for example Ludwig Erhard a
former chair Chancellor of West then
West Germany was a member of the Mont
Pelerin Society I believe that during
the Reagan administration in the United
States of participants on economic task
forces in the Reagan administration
something like one-third were members of
the Mont Pelerin Society so it's an
International Society of believers in
the free market and who believe
individuals who believe that the ideal
government is the government that
governs least
and who look forward to a society in
which government governs less than it
now govern what's Mount Pelerin Mont
Pelerin was simply where they held the
first meeting Hayek could hope that the
organization might be named after
thinkers that he was fond of in fact he
originally wanted to call it perhaps the
act and Tocqueville Society so it's
something that Tocqueville was someone
who really was influential and Hayek's
thought however there could not be
agreement as to who to name the society
after so they simply named it after
where they met Acton was he was a
British political theorist and historian
primary
historian during the 19th century I
believe he died early in the 20th
century this book is published by st.
Martin's Press how'd you sell it to him
well I'll tell you I got in contact with
an editor at st. Martin's Michael
Flamini who had published other books in
this area he was interested in it and
st. Martin's has done an excellent job
in bringing the book to publication and
I think that they're there they're an
outstanding publisher do you have any
idea how many the first run on it is you
know that I don't know I'm afraid to say
but it's something that I know they've
already ordered a second printing so I
was delighted to hear that the ultimate
message you say in fatal conceit another
one of his books near the end of his
life was life has no purpose but itself
Hayek wasn't agnostic so he did not have
a religious view of the world or a
supernal view of morality but his idea
was that the the justification for
capitalism for a free market
libertarianism is that it creates more
material goods that people have a higher
standard of living that it leads life to
be more flourishing more abundant it's
the medical breakthroughs it's the
technology that allows us to have a
higher standard of living and that from
his non-religious perspective of the
world life has no purpose but itself and
that was his message in the road in the
fatal conceit I found this footnote page
390 at the end of the chapter 37 I want
you to want to read it he says I don't
have many strong dislikes I admit that
as a teacher I have no racial prejudices
in general but there were certain types
and conspicuous among them the Near
Eastern populations which I still
dislike because they are fundamentally
dishonest it was a type which in my
childhood in Austria was described as
Levantine typical of people of the
eastern Mediterranean but I encountered
it later and I have a profound dislike
for the typical Indian students at the
London School of Economics which I admit
are all one type Bengali money-lending
sons they are to me at
festival type I admit but with not with
any racial feeling I have found a little
of the same amongst the Egyptians yeah
what is that well I think that Hayek is
someone who did Express cultural
stereotypes I placed that as a footnote
rather than in the main text because I
felt that it's the truth and therefore
it should be in the book at the same
time I don't feel that it really was
relevant to most of his life or thought
he was born in 1899 in a thoroughly
prejudiced Society primarily
anti-semitic I suppose an example and
within that society he was highly
progressive he was someone an example
might be someone who was very
progressive and born in the Old South in
1899 who was completely egalitarian and
their political outlooks believed in
equality and so forth and yet at the
same time could occasionally make a
statement that would strike us today as
racist so I think it's something that
it's important that it's acknowledged
and it's stated and at the same time not
over emphasized so it's it's a facet of
his personality and outlook but I don't
believe an important facet another
picture in the book is him in World War
one what did he do in World War one
which side was he on well Hayek was was
born in the austro-hungarian Empire in
1899 so in World War one which was 1914
to 1918 he would have been a young man
at the age of 17 he enlisted in the
Austrian army and fought on the Italian
front but once again it's something that
I think it's difficult to expect 17-year
olds to do anything other than to fight
for the country of which they're
currently I did say you got a chip
knocked out of his head with it some
kind of a rifle or somebody fired in it
World War one was still very
old-fashioned warfare compared to some
of what were more recently used to more
recently and he had a number of
life-threatening experiences one time he
was fired at and indeed it the bullet
actually grazed his skull and a little
chip of a
chip of bone came out which he didn't
even notice at the time as a result of
the battle on another occasion he was in
an airplane that almost crashed so he
had a number of experiences like that
and later in life he would almost laugh
about them as he discussed them in terms
of it was something that he'd been
through those sorts of experiences
though during World War one early in the
discussion you said that you were out in
Santa Barbara at you're an independent
scholar what's that mean independent
scholar I'm not affiliated with any
university or college I'm a writer and
I've just written the book on Friedrich
Hayek I've revised several of my
father's books were some of the leading
textbooks in the area of history of
political thought and comparative
politics I've revised several of them
great political thinkers introduction to
political thinkers today's isms and I've
also written on the the British
economist Edwin cannon who's at the
London School of Economics so I guess
that's what an independent scholar is I
can't before is nowhere I can't escape
going back to is it Arthur
Rupp Arthur Roop Bruce Abell that are
you PE I apologize to mr. hoop I keep
getting his name wrong as a old little
richard fan and especially records buyer
years and years ago tell us more about
that is that company still in existence
no art was involved with specialty
records he founded it in the late 1940s
and then sold it in the early 1960s and
there were many people who were on his
label who became leading stars I think
art once told me that one year he had to
pay ninety five percent marginal income
tax and I think that led him to his
free-market views and some of his
interest in people like Friedrich Hayek
who's on the who was on those who were
on those labels besides Little Richard
and Sonny Bono well a little Richard
Sonny Bono
he had I'm afraid to say that's an
aspect that I'm not as familiar I'm but
but where is he live now art also lives
in Santa Barbara how old a man is art is
83 how much money did he put into this
fund well the found a
at this point in time has about 15 to 20
million dollars of assets and in time
it'll have something like forty to fifty
million dollars of assets and how many
people work there at this point in time
there's art one secretary and yours
truly and so what do you do how do you
get your what's the plan well at this
point in time the foundation is still in
the startup mode and we're attempting to
develop things like prizes and
fellowships and research and it's
something that I think that we'd like to
see the the the foundation play a role
in the formulation of public policy and
ideas why didn't you call it the Hayek
Foundation well the foundation has been
in existence for a number of years in a
somewhat embryonic stage and it's only
been in the last couple of years that it
has moved to a more active stage now is
are there places around the world where
Hayek's names on the door absolutely
there is a college in guatemala that's
named after Hayek there's of course the
the the Hayek auditorium at at Cato and
other places like that that have his
name on it but as he himself mentioned
he said after he received the Nobel
Prize that he received honorary
doctorates but none of them he said from
a really prestigious institution it was
more places I won't say them by saying
that there then second-rate but in terms
of it wasn't Harvard and Yale and
Princeton that gave Harvard that gave
Hayek honorary degrees so it's still the
case that the idea is that he put
forward are not the popular ideas or the
common ideas in academia rather it's
still more along the idea that as
recently as ten or eleven years ago the
leading economics textbook writer and
Nobel laureate could make statements
like the Soviet Union is the an example
of the effectiveness of a command
economy so these are ideas that still
have a long way to go before they're
implemented in public policy you write
his introduction of the social
humanities was in a class on the
elements of philosophy the teacher spoke
about Aristotle and said that Aristotle
quote
ethics as consisting of three parts
morals politics and economics when Hayek
heard this his reaction was well these
are the things I want to study it had a
comic after effect when I went home and
told my father I know what I'm going to
study I'm going to study ethics I think
that Hayek is someone who had a
genuinely interdisciplinary approach
it's not something where he's just an
economist or he's just a political
philosopher of footer or is just a
moralist he's someone who really is
trying to look at a wide variety of
issues and discover their
interconnections how does the economic
system in the political system and the
moral system interact how to do all the
aspects of a societal order function
together and it's it's not something
that can be looked at in isolation it's
something that has to be looked at in a
more holistic manner and I think that
that's really Hayek's ultimate message
is it's the moral aspect in terms of
that questions of politics and economics
are not just questions that are
technical questions that have
objectively right and wrong answers
their questions about how do people want
to live how are people organized how can
we create the best society and Hayek's
argument was that because there are so
many people in society knowledge is
fragmented because knowledge is so
fragmented among all the members of a
society you have to create a society in
which fragmented knowledge can be most
utilized this is most likely to happen
in a capitalist society and it's a
society that in particular prices and
profits pay play a crucial role there
ways to communicate information that
that's how we should look at prices and
profits as ways to communicate
information among individuals who have
divided knowledge where is he buried
he's buried in Vienna where he was born
and that's a that's a picture of his
gravestone and he just modestly says FA
Hyack 1899 to 1992 what was this the
last couple of years of his life like
and what did he die of
he was just he was it was it was a he
suffered illness during his last years
and it was simply a matter of he was was
almost 93 years old he was not able to
write or give interviews for his during
his last several years but he still was
occasionally able to answer questions
that would be forwarded to him as
recently as a few months before he
passed away his son was able to read him
a question from a reporter and he gave a
rather detailed response indicating that
his mind remained sharp to the end he
undoubtedly had periods that were
stronger and weaker as he grew older and
during his illness and so forth but he
retained his faculties to the end you
told us when you arrived that they don't
call you Alan but they call you Lanny I
go by Lanny so my friends call me Landy
and how long did it take you to write
the book well I worked on this book for
over seven years so it was it was a long
project here's the cover of the book and
that's friedrich hayek on the cover
author of road to serfdom our guest has
been Alan eben Stein we thank you very
much thank you